i think that after a week or so of
forensic
archaeological work by gloucestershire
police they are now in a position to
actually start the excavation work in
the cellar the basement
of this cafe in gloucester this as you
say is all linked to the disappearance
of 15 year old mary best home who went
missing back in 1968 she was working a
shift at the cafe
and was last seen at a bus stop and she
was going to see her
boyfriend at the time now her
disappearance has long been linked to
the serial killer
fred west who of course was charged with
12
murders of young women he committed
suicide before uh
trial we've had an update from detective
chief inspector john
turner who is leading this fresh
investigation the big lines from
what my chat uncovered with him was that
they have found
six voids underneath this cellar six
areas
i was informed late on friday evening
last week that
they had discovered a void within the
basement area within the toilet
and when they put a drill hole hole in
they identified
via a cadaver dog which is a body
recovery dog
a minor to medium indication of some
interest within that void
specifically because we we've heard last
night from you that there are some
photographs taking some imagery from the
production company can you
shine any light on exactly what they
found yeah they put in an endoscope and
they
found what i would describe as a grainy
image of
of what looked like to me blue material
right okay and the significance of that
the significance is when mary went
missing in 1968 she was wearing a blue
coat a blue white dress and had a blue
bang
with a the production company thought
that was clearly significant
which is why they brought that to our
attention now this you said there was a
void
in a toilet in the basement did you say
yes yeah okay
when you say void do you just expand on
that was it a voyages
through through ground penetrating radar
they can say if their
anomalies within the ground what they're
saying is
below the surface area of the concrete
and tiles
there is a void which is a hole within
within the ground which is an
a anomaly what the gpr won't say is
what's in that void but it will say that
eight
or a hole is within the ground okay tell
us about the work that then since then
once you're informed what's been going
on with your officers in the last week
well what what's been going on for the
last few days we've
we've been working with a team of um
forensic archaeologists and
anthropologists to go over the data
provided by the production crew with
that with their own gpr
equipment we've had to carry out half
the safety
assessments for enclosed space working
because of the basement
um we actually employ structural
engineers because we are going to
excavate to make sure it's safe to do so
um a couple days ago we identified the
tiles over the toilet area are actually
asbestos
so we're gonna have to do an awesome how
to safety work to get those removed
um safely and clearly the product of the
gpr crew informed me yesterday that
they'd actually found six voids within
the basement
um two to confirm of what the production
company found and then a further four
in the um back end of of the basement
towards the road
was it was it two that the production
company had found so if you found a
further four
in the same sort of area by the toilet
or spread out no
further spread out some in the corners
and and some towards the end um
towards the uh the the roadway
effectively
uh dan has something gone wrong really
here
in the police investigation after all
this took place the
disappearance 50 years ago the fred west
case
was a number of years ago and yet it's
apparently taken the television
documentary makers to unearth this
evidence shouldn't the police have been
on it
the question that i put to the officer
later in that interview which will bring
you i did say whether or not he thought
this was a mistake at the time of the
investigation
he used um he said it wasn't a mistake
he said that the officers investigating
at the time
had had conflicting evidence as to
whether or not fred west had carried out
building work
back in the late 60s when mary went
missing in the cellar
at the uh the bottom of the the cafe
there um
his words were that at the time of the
investigation
that went into sort of folklore as he
said um and it wasn't sufficient
evidence to have to start
any form of excavation or any
assessments at the cafe i did
push him on that saying there are many
people saying why wasn't there at least
some ground penetration radar work
carried out
um he said with the evidence that has
come to light since the production
company
that is why he feels now this is the
time to
carry out this investigation that of
course will raise further questions if
if anything
significant is found one final point
which is significant
is that the detective did reveal that
the cafe
basement sits above an ancient burial
ground
not uncommon in roman towns and
there is a chance that anything found
there could be unrelated
to the disappearance of mary he has
informed mary's family
about that they have said that they are
very happy that this
excavation work is being carried out and
they hope that this will be a chance to
to put mary to rest
and hopefully bring conclusion to the
story the
um excavation work will start a team
will be going in tomorrow morning
and it will last around two weeks we've
been told